l'estaminet le café culture de magny les
hameaux fêtait samedi ses dix ans une
soirée concert placé volontairement sous
le signe de l'improvisation et pour
l'occasion le parrain bernard lubat est
venu avec son acolyte jean pierre drouet
pour jouer une musique aux gens
indescriptible à l'aide d'instruments
parfois très insolite là le public
aujourd'hui il va de la dictée qu'est ce
que je pense de ça qu'est ce qui se
passe parce que c'est pas du rock c'est
pas du tout brillé durant ne sais pas
on
décalé délurée débridée les adjectifs ne
manquent pas pour qualifier la
performance du duo complice depuis 2002
l'estaminet multiplie les genres
éclectique on a aussi bien eu du ciné
pour des bébés un deux trois semaines et
puis on a des choses aussi pour tous les
âges et aussi pour tous les goûts et
tous les publics le prochain spectacle
guézoui petit oiseau se jouera le 9
février à 20h30 pour les enfants dès 2
ans avec toujours une politique
tarifaire fraises accessible un carnet
de dix places coûte 40 euros